we weren't gonna miss our friends
getting married oh who got married
you did tv shows are able to shoot
multiple takes to get the right shot
but many of the best moments from
friends didn't end up using the perfect
take at all
from chandler's cabinet bing rachel's
awkward hangover and
lots and lots of very literal monkey
business
the show has plenty of unscripted
moments that contribute to making it so
memorable
let's have a look and see how good your
friends trivia is
you're funny i'm funny
oh thank god to start us off
we have to acknowledge the talent of the
dummy prop
it definitely gets the perfect reaction
from rachel in this scene
actors david schwimmer and cole sprouse
didn't tell aniston about the dummy
trick before
filming appropriate considering the
episode was about playing jokes on each
other
understandably aniston was shocked by
the joke and she even shouted
christina applegate's comedy chops and
sassy remarks brings
so much to scenes it feels like she's a
regular the trouble she has with phoebe
and baby emma's name
makes it obvious that she's definitely
not though
what makes it even funnier is the fact
that applegate was actually struggling
to get it right
phoebe oh that's a funny noise to be
fair
phoebe can sound odd if you don't know
that it's a name
phoebe why does she keep making that
noise
we definitely swoon every time paulo is
on screen
even more so when he is letting the
italian flow
the perfect romantic language for the
very suave man
that being said all of paulo's italian
dialogue was a surprise
since the writers let the actor do his
thing and romance the heck out of rachel
what a tutorial
sorry ross but we definitely prefer
paulo's over yours
would you please just
chandler definitely banged himself in
this hilarious scene
honestly we're not sure whose reaction
is better aniston trying to stifle her
laughter or
perry with his stoic yet very defeated
look
it's pretty wild that the beloved sitcom
had both billy crystal
and robin williams appear in the central
perk what's crazier is that the scene
wasn't even meant to take place at all
that's right crystal and williams were
actually filming something else nearby
and after swinging by the set it was
decided that they should appear in the
show
do you mind if we said yeah could you
scooch keep on scooching
the morning after ross and rachel's wild
night in vegas
brings some pretty rude awakenings i'm
just glad we didn't do anything
stupid she said it may seem harsh but
drunkenly getting married is pretty
rough
it would definitely make a normal
hangover that much worse
while matthew perry was known for being
a master improviser within scenes
even he had a hard time keeping it cool
with this one
alright look i'm gonna need an actual
answer here okay
the paper bag grab was rehearsed but in
the moment
perry grabbed it with far more vigor
than usual this is a scene that easily
could have been redone
but the beauty of friends was that they
kept the spontaneous moments they were
gifted on
set donald trump wants his blue blazer
black
here we have an example of the classic
word slip up
while they could have moved on the rest
of the cast joined in for the fun and
used the opportunity to ridicule the
clever chandler bing in perry's defense
it is a bit of a tongue twister
can you say blue blazer black three
times fast or wait
blue blazer back blue blazer back he
wants it back
did you know marcel appeared in eight
episodes that's more than most guest
actors and
honestly we're not surprised while it's
one thing to improvise with skilled
actors
it's hard to beat the spontaneity of a
live monkey while the monkey was well
trained it
definitely threw actors for a loop every
now and then by well uh
monkeying around the monkey just goes
right to the ceiling while ross does a
great job at
not being a great bagpipe player it's
phoebe who steals the scene in this one
[Applause]
actress lisa kudrow brings her best
smelly cat vibes here
she's definitely testing all the actors
in this scene with the wild whaling
just look at them trying not to laugh
while many of the unscripted moments
that made the final cut were comedic
every now and then friends really tugged
on the heartstrings with tender and
vulnerable scenes
we're great together you know you can't
deny it
this scene is a definite tearjerker
while the dialogue in the scene was
planned
the tears welling up in carol's eyes
weren't those special real moments
definitely contributed to making the
friends series so memorable
are they on a break are they not on a
break
after a while it got hard to keep track
but when ross was marrying emily
he was definitely on a break with rachel
take the emily
take the rachel talk about a major
freudian slip
it's pretty obvious who he was going to
be on a break with after that flub
while the name mix-up in this scene
wasn't improvised it was inspired by a
flub that schwimmer had made in a prior
scene
and the writers scooped it up turning it
into comedy
gold while some flubs are obvious this
one
definitely passed through the cracks in
editing it's quite subtle but if you
listen
very carefully you can hear the chandler
doesn't say
man but matt i'll see you man
hear that definitely a t sound
it's possible loads of chandler's
sarcastic lines
are ridiculous and we're not sure how he
comes up with some of these zingers
did you know this was actually only
meant to be a scoff
leave it to perry to bring this very
very random line to the scene
you have to stop the q-tip when there's
resistance no need to clean your ears
that really was a q-tip analogy
this improvised bit was actually one of
perry's favorite lines from the series
whenever we're surprised the first thing
we do is grab a lamp because
that makes so much sense right okay
maybe not but for whatever reason that
was david schwimmer's instinct
while schwimmer offered up the weird
unscripted moment
it was matthew perry who really milked
it and made that scene
so enjoyable she's talking
how you doing joey not so hot apparently
while the sling in this scene was
written in it was only because it had to
be
after suffering a very real injury matt
leblanc was stuck in a sling and the
writers had to work with it
did you tell the doctor you did it
jumping up and down on your bed it is a
very
joey reason let's be real we know joey
would absolutely jump on a bed with so
much enthusiasm he would actually injure
himself
if rachel hadn't left barry farber
viewers would never have had the chance
to witness the on and off again madness
of ross and rachel
however the truth is rachel never left
barry farber at all
the man she left was barry finkel i know
that some girl is going to be
incredibly lucky to become mrs barry
finkel we're not quite sure why they
would have changed his name after the
pilot
but we're glad she left barry anyway
whatever his last name might have been
in the heartfelt final episode matthew
perry
didn't miss a beat to throw in a final
sarcastic chancellor line
okay should we get some coffee sure
where obviously they'd be going to
central perk except
the irony of this line is that they
actually couldn't
by that point in filming the famous set
had already been taken down
so the comment wasn't actually that
sarcastic it feels appropriate that the
series ended with an off-the-cuff line
from one of our favorite friends
this scene in the uk with guest star
richard branson may not seem unscripted
as it's nothing too out of the ordinary
the fact is most of this scene was
actually improvised since branson
reportedly didn't have time to learn his
lines
you're gonna make me choose between you
and the hat i choose to hash
good choice in the first season monica's
apartment number is
five throughout the rest of the series
she mysteriously ended up living in
apartment 20
despite not actually moving apartments
the reason for this change was that the
view from her apartment wasn't
believably a lower floor
so the creators decided to move monica
up in the world quite literally to fix
the mistake
do you realize that at one time or
another we all lived in this apartment
did you know about any of these bloopers
which was the most surprising unscripted
moment
let us know what you think in the
comments time to hit those like and
subscribe buttons so you don't miss a
thing from us
here at the things